MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Ad handling at scale
requires a combination
of millions
of requests, rapid bids, and
serving the ads themselves.
Join us as we talk
to Unity about how
they've built out their ad
system on this episode of Stack
Chat.
Thanks for joining us, TJ.
Tell us a little bit more
about what Unity does.
THOMAS MERRITT: Thanks, Mark.
Unity builds a high definition,
3D, real-time graphics
rendering engine.
And it's used in game
development platforms as well
as a variety of
other applications
like automotive,
architecture, and film.
On the game development
side, we have
a number of back-end services
to support game publishers,
in particular the part I'm
involved in is monetization.
And we have in-app purchase
services as well as
ad services.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So, yeah, I'd love
to hear more about how
the architecture actually
supports all of the ad requests
that come in for a game.
THOMAS MERRITT: So
we get about tens
of thousands of ad
requests a second.
So it's pretty high volume.
And those all go into
a public GKE cluster.
And that service also
makes bid requests
to third parties at the rate
of about a million a second.
And those requests
are all public IP
addresses so that we can
get good performance going
to those bidders.
We had tried it on Outbound Map
and that didn't work as well.
Additionally, we have
a private GKE cluster
where all of our
support services
run for security reasons.
And that cluster is only
accessible internally.
And we also have
virtual machines
that are running a variety of
databases that also provide
support for our ad network.
Additionally, we
have data that's
going into Nats and
Kafka before hitting
other parts of our system.
And we have log-in
going to Stock Driver.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: What are
some of the other parts
of the system that
Kafka sends the data to?
THOMAS MERRITT: So other
parts of the system
are billing, business
intelligence, and some machine
learning systems that
make training models that
are used for making decisions
at various stages within our ad
network.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So was this
architecture built natively
on GCP?
Or was it migrated
from somewhere else?
THOMAS MERRITT: We migrated
from another cloud provider
into GCP about a year ago.
And in the prior
environment, we had
a lot of services that were
on [INAUDIBLE] [? verse ?]
machines.
We had some services
in Kubernetes.
We had a variety of
different CI/CD processes.
So early on in the
migration process,
we did some engineering
work to figure out
how we were going to
migrate our services.
We wanted to have a
consistent CI/CD pipeline
for all of our services in GCP.
And so a lot of the
pre-work was to upgrade
the CI/CD pipeline for all our
services to be standardized.
And that pipeline also
supported the GCP migration.
Additionally, getting the ad
serving component migrated over
required solving a couple of
technical problems around DNS
and just the volume of
traffic that we have.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So now that you've
got all this up
and running in GCP,
are there any changes
that you would make?
Or if you could go back, would
you do anything differently?
THOMAS MERRITT: We're pretty
happy with the structure
we have in GCP right now,
being on a standardized CI/CD
pipeline has been
really helpful for us.
It makes it easy to
deploy any services.
We have a process
for doing that.
And in particular,
changes that we are making
are migrating towards
managed database services
like [INAUDIBLE] and
dropping some of our more
customized database systems.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Sounds good.
Well thank you so much
for coming in today
and telling us about how you
built the ad request network.
THOMAS MERRITT:
Great to be here.
Thanks.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Check
out this deep dive
on building an advertising
platform on Google Cloud
Platform.
Thanks for watching and
make sure to subscribe
for more great Google
Cloud Platform content.
We'll see you next
time on Stack Chat.